well brian for the first time since 2017
the immigration program daca will now be
open to new
applicants now it protects undocumented
immigrants brought
to this country as children from being
deported
eight news now reporter orco mana
explains what this could mean for
nevadans this means the trump
administration has to fully restore daca
an obama era initiative now
approximately one million undocumented
immigrants including thousands here in
nevada
could benefit from it new applications
for daca which stands for deferred
action for childhood arrivals
have not been accepted for about three
years but on friday a federal judge
ordered the u.s department of homeland
security
to take in applications for immigrants
who qualify daca shield certain people
who came to the u.s as children
from deportation which means they can
stay in the country
for two years subject to renewal the
judge also said approved applicants
should get work permits that last for
two years
and current daca recipients known as
dreamers can travel abroad and return to
america
there are currently more than 640 000
dreamers in the u.s
and according to the american
immigration council over 12 thousand
dreamers
lived in nevada as of march 2020 local
attorneys say
many more can now be helped we thought
that we would have to wait until
president-elect biden came into office
for uscis to start accepting those
applications but this order is making it
very clear
that uscis has to accept them so there's
no longer
there's no longer a waiting period it's
time to it's time to apply
requirements for daca eligibility
include having no serious criminal
convictions
arriving in the u.s before age 16 living
here since at least 2007
and earning an american high school
diploma ged
or serving in the military many are
calling this new order a victory for
dreamers but the fight isn't necessarily
over yet
a dhs spokesman says while the
department will comply with the decision
they are working with the justice
department on next steps to appeal
reporting in las vegas orca mana 8 news
now